esta mañana han continuado las protestas
en irán especialmente en las
universidades en algunas de las grandes
universidades de tera pero no solamente
aquí en el noroccidente del país en
orumyie donde había sido aceptada marcha
mini para hacer sus estudios
universitarios también varios jóvenes se
protestaron y esto ya era después de una
noche donde estas protestas se
extendieron al menos en 20 ciudades del
país con imágenes que reflejan realmente
el sentimiento de lo que está pasando se
veían mujeres quitándose el velo algunas
de ellas quemándolo y quitándose el pelo
cortando selo como un acto de rebeldía
pero también se veía muchísimas actos de
violencia de muchos jóvenes contra las
autoridades de hecho se habla hasta el
momento de seis muertos entre ellos un
policía y varios de ellos heridos porque
refleja como el sentimiento de rabia que
tienen muchos de esos jóvenes contra la
represión a la que son sometidos hoy
están convocadas nuevas protestas en
pero el gobierno o el establecimiento
quiere decir que esto ya es una sedición
que esto está elementos opositores que
están abusando de la muerte de macsa a
mí ni hablan también intervención de
elementos extranjeros pero sin embargo
los que están en las calles los rechazan
y dicen que están ahí pidiendo por sus
libertades y sobre todo por los derechos
de las mujeres